the best impact you can have I believe
is
providing somebody with a good job we
shouldn't get too
um flowery about uh sustainability and
impact and that uh the only way somebody
can have impact is by starting a company
that's going to change the world or fix
every problem that's out there it's
actually much more basic and achievable
and it's something that many CEOs and
many compan have actually been doing for
decades way before the word
sustainability became part of the
business
nomenclature welcome to 20-minute
leaders just sit back relax and learn
from the leaders of today it's a journey
each one is different unique inspiring
let's get
started this episode is powered by Jay
Ventures a community-driven VC Fund in
Silicon Valley in partnership with lch
sponsored by hom Ventures hippo
Insurance upost Labs synergy Global H at
Stanford leap Birthright Excel serona
partners and in media partnership with
ctec welcome to 20-minute leaders today
I am honored to be joined by Ron gonan
the founder and CEO of closed loop
partners and new york-based investment
firm comprised of Venture Capital Growth
Equity private Equity project finance
and an innovation Center focused on
building the circular economy prior to
closed loop Partners Ron was the Deputy
Commissioner of Sanitation in recycling
and sustainability in New York City in
the blueberg administration and the
co-founder and CEO of recycle Bank Ron
received an MBA from Columbia business
school and has been an edun professor at
his Alma matter since
2010 Ron Gan welcome to 20-minute
leaders thank you so much for joining me
from New York I'm so honored to have you
here we're going to have such a good
time how are you I'm doing well thank
you and looking forward to the
conversation I I wish I could show just
you know 30 degrees to you right where
we were at before but this sun is too
beautiful and bright today that it's not
allowing the webcam to see so we're
settling for your nice wall with a plant
but but I trust me the offices are
beautiful I saw a second ago H Ron your
your background is is so fascinating um
from being you know a consultant with
deoe and then entrepreneur running a
company going to public policy working
for the Bloomberg Administration as
Deputy Commissioner of Sanitation
Recycling and sustainability I I have to
tell you I still can't figure out where
do I put the the different pieces so I'm
still learning on that on on a personal
level and then also founder and CEO of
closed loop Partners which is a I think
a beautiful name for for a group that is
considering the circular economy so Ron
thank you so much for joining me looking
through your journey was this always the
the trajectory knowing that you're going
to be dealing with the circular economy
with sustainability already from a young
age the the inspiration was always to be
doing this I feel very fortunate to be
in the position I am today I'm one of
those people that in high school when my
parents friends would ask me what are
you planning to do with your life and I
would talk about my interest in uh
sustainability and impact uh they would
sort of shake their heads and say you
know you seem like a good student and a
smart kid uh wait until you have to
start paying bills and start a family
and and then you'll understand that you
have to go on a a different path and I
feel very fortunate to be somebody that
has really been able to uh fulfill their
um aspiration to pursue this kind of
professional uh lifestyle so there's
been a number of ups and downs and
twists and turns uh along the way and
Lessons Learned but uh the trajectory
has always been um something that uh
I've planned for and wanted to
pursue May of 2004 H you've spent a few
years doing Consulting before that but
you're running a sustainability company
called recycle bank today you know if
everybody you know claps for you and
there's different funds that are that
are you know tailored exactly for you I
don't think that was the case in in 204
really what what was that experience
like uh it it was an interesting
experience uh so I went back to business
school at Columbia business school in
2002 previous to that I'd been in
Management Consultant at deoe and had a
great experience uh learning about
business and software and it actually
gave me a really important foundation
but I realized after a certain period of
time in management consulting uh that I
was getting into my mid and late 20s and
my real passion was in this area of
sustainability and the intersection
between uh social impact and producing
great financial returns which I thought
was where the world should be heading
and so went back to Business School
Colombia school and my first day there
uh everyone was asked what do you want
to do when you graduate and there were a
bunch of responses regarding investment
Banks and strategy Consulting and hedge
funds and then I communicated my
interest around building a company at
this intersection between sustainable
business practices and maximizing
returns
and
silence people literally thought that I
had come to the wrong meeting and that I
was actually supposed to be a teacher
college or at um the program for you
know social work
and asked me you know are you in the
right place I said absolutely um this is
going to be my my focus and then people
realized okay he is in the business
school they probably let him in because
when Colombia has a situation where some
hedge fund guy or I Banker gets arrested
for malfant or this or that Colombia
will be able to point to this guy who's
doing something good with his NBA not
making any money but at least something
good and know fast forward while I was
at business school I founded my
co-founded my first company recycle bank
and Columbia business school actually
became the seed investor uh in uh in the
company uh and I um ended up uh
graduating and having lost my company
while at Columbia with them as the seed
investor un unbelievable and so you mov
then from business school the
entrepreneurship scene to public policy
with with Michael Bloomberg's
Administration holding a a really
interesting position at a really
interesting point in time you know from
2012 to 2014 it from what I recall this
was also a time where where things were
were really picking up and people were
beginning to understand the importance
of what you do and and and I'm assuming
whoever held this position 30 years ago
probably had a different experience than
than the one you had in 2012 what was
that like for you both with with
Bloomberg but in general in the in that
public policy
space well interestingly the position
was actually created by the deputy mayor
at that time someone named Cass Holloway
who looked around and recognize that the
way sanitation was being managed in New
York City which is the largest
sanitation agency in North America was
Antiquated and very inefficient from a
financial standpoint the city was paying
$400 million a year to export waste to
out estate landfills when much of that
could be recycled locally and so the
deputy mayor created this new position
called uh Deputy Commissioner for
sanitation Recycling and sustainability
and I was recruited uh into the
Bloomberg Administration to uh build out
uh the next um iteration of what uh the
sanitation department should look like
which is really uh the next um
generation way to to manage resources in
a city incredible and so spending that
time right after you know being in in
the business world the entrepreneurship
world is that was that an easy
transition a very trivial one for you
how how how did that personally feel
going through that well I think joining
the Bloomberg Administration was a type
of once in a-lifetime yeah experience uh
I encourage everybody to
pursue uh public off office um in some
capacity if they can sometime in their
life I think it's a very rewarding thing
to be able to serve your community but I
think doing so can be very challenging
with lots of ups and downs and you have
to pick the right moments and time to do
it uh fortunately I came into a uh
Administration that I think uh is was
very very unique and very special and
I'm very grateful for that and I was
able to learn a lot about how Mayor
Bloomberg had put this management team
together and how he managed and I was
also able to supplement my business
skills with things that you have to
learn in government that you can then
take back the business and the most uh
Salient of those skills was how to build
consensus uh in government even with a
powerful mayor like Mayor Bloomberg
there's multiple constituents that need
to agree before you can move forward and
developing that skill set and then
bringing it back to business I found to
be very rewarding I I love it so you
know talking about you know the most re
recent meaningful Endeavor that that
You' were working out over the last
several years closed loop Partners I I
think that you know I got to spend some
time looking over the different both
companies we you you've invested and I
think there there are a few things that
make you very unique in the market both
the fact that you found an organization
that is acting really across the whole
spectrum of investing from Venture
Capital to to equity to all sorts of
different really cool things but but
what's really interesting is the fact
that you know it becomes remarkably
noticeable as you enter the focus that
you have on sustainability and impact
and and it took me a few minutes but
then I made the connection between you
know the closed loop partners and
circular economy so I'd love to start on
on the latter circular economy what's
happening to our world today in your
perspective and where are where are you
personally pushing us to move forward to
in the circular economy type of World
um what we've been presented by many
economists uh many Business Leaders many
governments in the western world is that
we live in a uh capitalist system that
uh promotes a meritocracy and whoever
works the hardest and has the best
product uh wins and is rewarded and
that's what we've been told as the
system that we live under and how things
are structured and when you actually
take a look at the
system you begin to realize that that's
not actually the case the way our
economy has actually been structured
over the past 75 years is not as a
meritocracy it's not as a system where
the person that works the hardest or the
person that has the best product ends up
winning we've actually created a system
that is designed for the financial
benefit of certain industries that
figured out a way to Lobby themselves
into a partnership with certain decision
makers in government and the net result
of that is that we have a manufacturing
system that's based on a linear economy
where you extract the natural resource
like oil or uh ore for metal um you use
that natural resource in a design
process where the product is designed to
be used essentially once and then
disposed of in a landfill and then you
start that process all over again for a
new product that type of system works in
the Financial best interest of the
extractive industries oil gas Timber
Mining and in the best financial
interest of the landfill
Industries but it's not the optimal
system it's not what a true capitalist
would design or build a true capitalist
would build a system in which you
optimized for efficiency where you used
Material Science to develop Advanced
products where you don't have to drill
into the Earth or extract natural
resources that's very expensive to do
it's very harmful for the environment
and you would Design Systems where you
can continually recycle and continually
reuse materials so you don't have to pay
for landfills and that was a recognition
that I had and a number of other people
had in that the most effective and
efficient economy that we should be
operating under is one that's circular
where you're continually reusing
materials and that was really the
Genesis behind launching cloth with
partners and what was the rationale
behind performing that out of multiple
investment arms that have unique
expertises in their own domains you know
these investment arms are vastly
different in the way that they're doing
diligence the way that they're
understanding the economy and and the
world as a whole some of them are more
Tech driven some of them are more
business driven how how do you
rationalize through this sort of
community that you're building here or
this sort of
organization I was interested in
designing a firm that would be able to
invest anywhere along the gross
trajectory of a Sol solution I knew that
we were starting the firm at a point in
which the circular economy was at a nent
stage and so we needed to be able to
have the flexibility to identify a
bottleneck identify solution and then
apply the right type of capital towards
that solution and so we chose the
industry sectors of uh consumer products
and packaging fashion and apparel food
and egg and electronics and we look at
the supply chains from A to Z in each
one of those Industries identify where
the bottlenecks are identify
where their Solutions and then if it's
an early stage type solution we have a
venture fund that can apply Capital if
it's an
infrastructure type solution that
requires project financing or debt we
pull it out of our infrastructure fund
if it's a opportunity to acquire a
company and scale it we pull comp
Capital out of our PE fund if it's a
situation where we don't have a solution
in the market and we recognize that
somebody needs to incubate a solution we
have Innovation Center that will
literally uh incubate a solution and
commercialize it and that's the
structure behind the firm that enables
us to invest anywhere along the gross
trajectory of a
solution right the experience of
building the team for such a firm you
know it doesn't require just the
traditional expertise of of being able
to deploy capital and assess the
business and you know the unit economics
and and the way the markets are run but
you're requiring people to both share a
similar Vision to yours and to
participate in this in this impact
driven mindset what what was that like
building out the team that that is now
pretty big how many people are your
closed loop Partners now uh we're a
little bit north of 40 people wow
amazing so what was that like building
it from the ground up well uh going back
to my Columbia business school
experience is uh after I exited my first
company uh recycle Bank uh Columbia
business school uh came and said hey
we're actually interested in building
out a program uh around impact investing
and socially responsible development of
business and you can see how things
begin to change so when I arrived in
2002 people thought I would actually was
in the wrong uh class and meeting in
school when I was talking about social
impact fast forward to eight years later
2010 and Columbia business school is now
saying hey would you be interested in in
in launching a course uh on this and uh
so I went back and started teaching a
course on uh entrepreneurship and social
impact and one of the key lessons I try
to communicate to the students was the
three most important things I've learned
in business are number one people number
two people number three
people uh and so uh that's a long way to
answer your question around how I built
a team is that um over the course of my
business career i' I've Had The Good
Fortune to to come into contact with
really phenomenal people who have helped
me uh pursue my
Ventures um and have stayed very loyal
to me and and my vision and I've also
been able to recruit really uh
phenomenal people and so the development
of close loop Partners was a combination
of this group of people that have really
been with me for most of my career as
co-founders and um the the ventures I
launch and then other people that have
either approached me or I've gone out
and and recruited but the most important
piece of this for anyone else out there
looking to start a business is I've
learned to invest an enormous amount of
my time in
recruiting people and developing culture
I love it I love it and I'm going to
using this as a segue um I your time is
hugely valuable Ron and so I'm going to
be very selfish and going to take up the
last few minutes that we have for myself
because I want to start a company sooner
rather than later and I want to make
sure that I have a positive impact on
the world and I want to participate in
the circular economy and I want to make
sure that I am a part of a solution and
not a part of a problem and so as I go
about ideating for my own company
whatever it may be what are some things
that I should be keeping in mind very
practically to help me as a future
CEO build the right vision and have the
right North Star as I move
forward the best impact you can have I
believe is providing
somebody with a good job we shouldn't
get too
um flowery about uh sustainability and
impact and that uh the only way somebody
can have impact is by starting a company
that's going to change the world or fix
every problem that's out there it's
actually much more basic and achievable
and it's something that many CEOs and
many companies have actually been doing
for decades way before the word
sustainability became part of the
business nomenclature the best impact
you can have is Prov by providing
somebody a good job and a good job is
one in which you provide someone
employment in which they feel challenged
when they come to work every day
intellectually uh it's one in which they
feel like they're uh respected for
whatever it is they're doing I don't
care if it's cleaning the bathrooms or
making multi- billion dollar m&a
decisions whatever that job is they
should feel like they're being uh
respected and uh that there's
transparency in terms of uh how
decisions are made and so that's the
that's the that's the basic and if
you're just doing that you're actually
having a really important impact on the
world beyond that I would look at what
is my company doing that's making some
person's life better or some communities
better or some part of our environment
uh better how do I look through a lens
that helps me see uh with greater
Clarity what is the impact that I'm
having how early did you know that this
was sort of your calling and that and by
the way I love that your pres
representation of impact and
sustainability it's not just the you
know the traditional way that it's being
presented today that either you're doing
impact or you're not but there's also
variability there and and there's ways
to make tremendous impact without
necessarily H trying to be you know
overly flowy about it but how early did
you know that this is something that
that you really are deeply passionate
about and I see that it's something that
is constantly you know in in your brain
and it's also obviously very evident
throughout your career that it's
something that you're keeping close
touch with how early did that does that
go very early I don't know exactly when
but very early I can tell you one of the
first instances of the Hat was actually
probably when I was 10 years old I grew
up with a single mom in Philadelphia in
the 1980s and uh for one year as my year
of of fourth grade uh I had to go to uh
one of the worst public schools in
Philadelphia and in the 1980s one of the
worst public schools in Philadelphia
during the crack epidemic it was not a
war zone but as close to a war zone that
you're going to get in America and I
looked around at that situation I even
distinctly remember this at 10 years old
and recognizing that this message that
we were getting that in America it's all
about pulling yourself up by the
bootstraps and just working hard and
whoever makes it makes it because of
their work ethic and whoever didn't is
because that they were lazy was a
complete fallacy and I looked around at
that school and
thought there's no way anyone's making
it out of here and and becoming some
type of great success I mean maybe it
happens every once in a while but the
person needs to be exceptional or their
parents need to be exceptional or some
aberration and then from there I got to
move on to a a good public school and
then uh even better in seventh grade I
got to go to one of the best private
schools on a scholarship uh in uh the
United States and so it further
emphasized for me having those
experiences that what actually was going
on in America was not capitalism it was
not
meritocracy it was a system in which who
you were born to and where you were born
was probably a 90% determinant of what
station you were going to have in life
and you could have all kinds of social
commentary on that but if we want to
speak strictly about
economics that's not optimizing for
economics or for your economy that's not
the hardest worker or the smartest
person getting the best
jobs it's just not how the system is is
working you can age agree with it
socially you could disagree with it
socially it's just not
capitalism um and that's probably the
first instance in my life of recognizing
that this system can be further
optimized and the world can be a better
place Ron thank you so much for these 20
minutes I gained so much inspiration and
I'm going to be revisiting this talk
quite a bit H in preparation for my own
startup one day and I can't wait to
share this with my friends and family it
really really was phenomenal and I and I
appreciate all the hard work that you've
done both on the public sector and in
the private sector which feeds back into
the public sector so thank you very much
for the circular economy and the closed
Lo partners and stay safe and stay
healthy thank you uh glad to be with you
today and enjoy the conversation thank
you thank you